so riley you wind up racing leah thomas
in the 200 yard freestyle
at the ncaa you tie
for fifth place talk to me about that
day
yeah so like i mentioned before you know
we're measuring swimming down to the
hundreds
so to go the exact same time down to the
hundredth
is pretty rare um it's pretty crazy to
do and so like you said we tied this was
the day after thomas won the national
title
and so we go behind the awards podium
where we're going to get our trophies
distributed to us and then we're kind of
paraded out
but the official looks at me and says
great swim you know we don't really
account for ties so we only have one
trophy
we're going to give that trophy to
thomas riley yours will eventually come
in the mail
great job and so i'm sitting there and
i'm like okay i understand we don't
account for ties it's you know
pretty rare to do
but can i ask you why you're adamant on
giving this trophy to thomas
especially after winning a national
title last night
um is there a reasoning and he looks at
me and says well we're just doing this
in chronological order and so
i realized what's happening now and i
asked him okay well we went the exact
same time
so what are you what are we being
chronological about um and he looks at
me and says for photo purposes thomas
has to have the trophy um you can pose
with the sixth place trophy since that's
what we have but yours will eventually
just come in the mail
and so
it was at this point that i was done
waiting for someone with some sort of
political power or someone with some
authority to change these guidelines to
say something
i took it upon myself as a 22 year old
girl to speak out on how crazy this is
because it was in this instance i
realized you know not only are we being
forced to compete against men changing a
locker room with men
we're being put on the back burner we're
being sidelined to men and this is
showing to me that the females category
is in total jeopardy here yeah
interesting to me that at this moment
all the so-called feminists have been
quiet
um let's we have an image of that uh
natalia if you can pull up the new york
post image um because what you're
talking about is true you have a
biological male that wound up holding
the trophy and
in fact it was it was a photo op i mean
it's very clear to me that the reason
that that happened was because
the woke media wanted their photo
opportunity so you see this image
immediately the size difference i think
stuns everyone um that that was what
registered in the minds of people who
didn't really realize how big leah was
in comparison um
you look at this image today and what
emotions do you feel thinking about that
moment and reliving that moment by just
looking at this picture
it's just honestly
frustration
but now looking back on it
i really hate to say right place right
time
but i do think that i was put in a
position where
it's given me a fantastic story to
really shine light on what this issue is
doing to female sports
um i think it's kind of god put me there
for a reason um
which is kind of crazy to say because
not to say i expected any of this to
come from it but i think it's great that
we're having this conversation we're
being explicitly shown what this is
doing to female athletes and so for that
reason
i can look at it a bit optimistically
now if you like the short clip you can
catch another one here or you can catch
the full episode right here
[Music]
you